you welcome to this video one night of
three playing extra something let's
let's play English from the Netherlands
around 2,300 rated ok so maybe try some
other line oh it's playing on a sideline
himself not turn your five yeah Bishop
g4 some is some played sometimes usually
leading to this kind of position in only
style set up
it's not a particularly active position
for black I guess this is also why it is
not not very popular it's played once in
a while but not often I don't see black
playing v5 p.m. it's just giving away
porn for nothing and if you cannot play
B 5 i'm not quite sure what your play is
yeah this is an idea preparing the six
going going from the the exchange em
okay yeah if I take probably Knight
takes Queen D 694 this type of this type
of thing
okay yeah I take with the Seaport you
will directly play b5 don't think don't
think this would be too great the sir
keeps control but um yeah II six was a
good move i guess to get some counter
play this is probably okay for black you
get to exchange some um some material
here you get some exchanges and then the
disadvantage in space is not so serious
okay but maybe I can try a bit here
okay so let's think about this I
probably need to go here and now we can
play that actually move yeah because of
the pressure on on d5 so but still ctx
be 8x be 95 and can do that
not sure shouldn't this be good for
white you
right since opening up and I've got the
a-bomb
now g5s rugby one case not playing that
at all mmm interesting
Wow sorry maybe just this one look I'm
sorry it isn't this simple simple end
okay the a porn should should be worth
something here
and maybe a t5 jack maybe if I first was
better and now okay but this is very
good now isn't it
yeah the upon the a porn should shoot
this side it's just providing reason
just promoting yeah very sudden end yeah
I don't think he can he can he can do
that now my night XD five maybe I'm
mistaken but I know the computer
actually agrees that why tessa is much
better here so this was a good decision
to take on me five I wasn't wasn't so
sure night XD five seems to be better am
like f night f takes d5 this yeah but
this is also quite good for white it
still da porn this is a really dangerous
now probably idiot he doesn't need to
play b5 really i can think you can just
just play em play solid moves like let's
say king here b6 just slowly improving
and then it it doesn't it doesn't hold
any blood be back any big come I'm it
doesn't have any any big trouble black
well not nothing bad happening yeah e6
was pretty good here so okay it was
clear that he had prepared it but
otherwise I think you are you too
passive and important is this idea this
is very very annoying for white your
queen is cut off if you play some snow
move this Bishop be fine ok you have you
have not a 2500 your queen is exposed
and the black has an excellent square
yonder form so what shouldn't consider
that
yeah this was ok for like so pretty
pretty equal ok thanks for watching